with a 19-point advantage barton  and barton misses short on those shots  front rim faku just knocked simmons down  big closeout by barton dwight howard is  back in  and this is tyrese maxie who had 39  against the nuggets in the first meeting  he misses there remember philly was  missing three regulars in that game they  started a very funky lineup  now capacitors gonna take his first  three no pump fake  and he got hit by maxi on the flyby  a maxi effort  [Applause]  by tyrese but it's a foul  [Applause]  you're gonna set a screen you're gonna  have faku gonna put a little shoulder  into it  i don't care you're six nine you better  get up  douglas by 19.